each of these models comprises hundreds
of individual parts you won't find any
plastic glue or batteries here the
trains and trucks consist exclusively of
intricately assembled pieces of wood
motors propelled forward by rubber bands
and there aren't just vehicles to choose
from either no one expected us to create
a musical instrument you can assemble
and play yourself we do there and enjoy
it like the old masters our customers
can build an instrument from the Middle
Ages the UK's company was founded in
Kiev in 2014 and has been exporting toys
to funds the world over ever since to be
successful with wooden models in the
plastic age every angle must be right
every detail must be exact it often
takes dozens of attempts until
everything is perfect
Engineers work hard to achieve their
what attracts them to it
it's always interesting to come up with
your own ideas and then turn them into
reality just community after the design
has been finalized they use a laser to
cut the pieces from thin plywood
customers can press them out of the
sheets at home and assemble them
according to a blueprint some 30 models
are now available with something for
everyone from beginners to professional
craftsmen but sometimes customers have
special requests - in Southeast Asia
from our partners asked us to put
something other than a ballerina in the
middle of the models that could
symbolize happiness for example the
ballerina isn't popular there it's
always about giving our customers things
that mean something to them then they
sell better
Assembly of the tract or model with 97
parts takes just 3/4 of an hour to
complete at least for an experienced
model maker the most complex models
consist of almost 600 parts analog
puzzles seem to be catching on again in
the digital world production is
currently running full speed ahead the
models still being packaged here will
end up all over the world in time for
Christmas the models are designed and
manufactured here in the Ukrainian
capital Kiev but less than 1/10 of
production remains in the country
overseas customers have long since
discovered the former starter Facebook
and Instagram spread the word even
without expensive advertising UGA's
sells its models in around 80 countries
and even big companies are interested in
a cooperation but what comes next the
goal is not to build bigger and bigger
models or become even more complex there
are already clear limits after which it
would be so difficult that most people
couldn't assemble them anymore we're
more concerned with aesthetics and
originality and tediousness doing
business like this innovative Wharton's
safe
incidentally UGA's stands for ukrainian
gears a name that aptly describes the
heart of these modern-day mechanical
toys